got some very good reviews but some bad
reviews and that was difficult from
humorless people yeah I should have
clarified
um and recently I got a I had a very
good experience with some reviews uh
including one from the great Stephen
King he tweeted to somebody somebody
said have you watched Barbarian with
Justin Long and Bill Skarsgard is
available on HBO they said to Stephen
King and Stephen King said yeah that
movie blew me away it was crazy crazy
good now who cares you might be saying
this is strictly what we call in the
podcast Biz a brag well you care and
it's your podcast that's true but it's
pretty lame of me to be just using this
as a platform to um regurgitate
something really positive that somebody
says okay I think it's okay and you know
what they say you take the good you take
the bad you take them both and there you
have you don't build up to quote the
opening song from The Facts of Life
let's do the show yes life could be a
dream life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short I am
your recently self-esteem boosted host
Justin Long
dude
and with me as always is uh my my smarty
loving co-host and brother Christian I
can't stop eating these they're
addictive they're like I feel like I'm
holding a little bag of heroin you are
acting like that you picked me Christian
kindly picked me up from um I play so I
didn't have to take an Uber uh and he
was eating some Smarties which I haven't
seen you do in a while and you could you
all just heard him eat some more I've
left over Halloween candy for some
reason they didn't the trick-or-treaters
weren't into the smarties I would have
been if I was a trick-or-treater I was
when I was a trick-or-treat I loved
Smarties so now I I see all these
Smarties left over in my house and
Marty's and uh if they're Smarties in my
house they they will be eaten by me I
can't I can't not eat them yeah you
looked very guilty of this little like
sheepish look on your face when you're
unwrapping um are there flavors in
Smarties of course of course the white
ones are the best oh huh that's right I
haven't had one in so long I'm kind of
kind of can I travel yeah kind of
curious um but you had Snickers what
else did you have in that it wasn't the
I hate to shame your candy oh really I
was good I had Gummy Bears I had a mix
of gummy bears Twix
um Snickers M M's it's a pretty good
assortment what do you want what do you
think Starburst but but just don't shave
my candy store what would you add to
that
um I would say Reese's Peanut Butter
Cups Reese's Pieces the little recipe I
love an Almond Joy yeah
um too much coconut obviously peanut
butter M M's or peanut M M's okay
um anyway I have some peanut M M's for
you oh really yeah big bag of them
um Catherine got them for you they're
delicious yeah it's your favorite right
yeah I think it's the perfect candy we
should ask that question again
candy we're gonna uh pretty soon we're
gonna be changing up the questions a
little bit that's right New Year oh yes
the year is winding down and um speaking
of Halloween and speaking of a good
review you got yeah so let's not uh I
don't want to just let that brag hang
out there on its own that was exciting
because he Stephen King was a I mean
still his like just such a huge part of
um my my pop culture experience and you
know he wrote some of my favorite stuff
I also wasn't allowed to read him until
I was of a certain age and so it was
really taboo he like you know talked
about some fun stuff when you're a
pre-teen boy naughty naughty stuff why
are we talking about Stephen King though
and uh good review I'll tell you why
because our guest today is responsible
for many reviews good and bad
um some of the stuff I've done who cares
but uh he's been reviewing movies for
decades now he is one of the legendary
film critics we have one of my favorites
as a kid uh I would say your favorite is
my favorite they got who wrote the book
my Bible my not the Bible my childhood
Bible it was just a list of it was a
book of film reviews that I read so much
so often that it the pages are all
frayed and it just looks like um it
looks like a you know really well-worn
book one of those like beloved beloved
books um let's say it looks like a Bible
owned by a very devout person like a
monk yeah but a monk's Bible
um our guest today is the film critic
Leonard Moulton Mountain at the movies
yeah he was the yeah tonight he was the
film critic
John Tash and Mary Hart and here we have
Leonard Mountain I'll never forget I
mean he was you know a big part of our
Lives yes when we were kids and
um and he was always so uh seemed so
fair and he would review any kind of
movie I like that he was open to well he
will talk about that um and what led him
to film criticism and what some of his
favorites are now and what constitutes a
good movie I was so curious to talk to
him and he was I had done his show a
couple years ago at a film festival in
Austin with his daughter Jesse they were
so kind to me and um it was just really
cool for childhood me to get to spend
some more time with him so uh without
spending more time talking about it here
it is here is my um my ketchup with uh
my childhood favorite the great film
critic Leonard Malton life could be a
dream sweetheart
we'll meet again
[Music]
Leonard I think you granted me the
authority to call you Leonard at one
point yes yeah I that that is a a
lifetime really oh that's so nice what
would I have to do to to break that what
would I have to do so if you if you
signed up for my class at USC I would
want you to call me perfect of course
that makes sense what is that class like
how do you T is it on film criticism no
it's not at all oh it's it's a
I'm the latest custodian of a famous
class that started in the early 60s that
George Lucas took oh wow and Ron Howard
attended this class it has this great
history huh and uh more recently uh Ryan
coogler took this class Oh Black Panther
director yeah yeah and and he's come
back with his with a couple of his films
oh wow and in fact there's nothing well
we screen new films just before they
open and have one or more of the
filmmakers there that's so cool and uh
and then I I'm yammering at them at the
beginning of the class and uh and
showing an old short subject that's how
I get in my licks for film history oh oh
because yeah you are um yourself such a
student such a a
knowledgeable student of film history um
it's it's how I learned so as much as I
did about
um film through your books I I won't
bore you or the audience well I'll do
that at some point in the show with how
much I admire you and I I'm so glad I
got the opportunity to tell you that in
person but you were such a big part of
my childhood and uh when it came to film
and falling in love with film
um so to get to meet you that time on
your podcast was
such a such a thrill for me you're
flattering me and that's just fine
um but I was I was surprised to learn
how early you started doing this when
you were just 18 in 1969 what prompted
that that you started writing so young
at 15 oh no I earlier than that oh
really I was probably oh I was
publishing my own fan Zine at age 13. oh
my God what what was the impetus for
that Leonard you were just uh I mean
you're a fan I wasn't I was an indoor
kid I had no no aptitude for sports
whatsoever
or or interest
and uh
uh I love watching TV and a lot of what
I watched on TV it turned out to be old
movies I was watching Laurel and Hardy
every day I was watching you know the
watching The Little Rascals every day I
was watching old cartoons every day I
was watching Walt Disney every week
not somebody from the Walt Disney
Company Walt Disney yeah not Walt Disney
himself just staring at him yeah what um
if you could recommend a Laurel and
Hardy movie because they're they were my
biggest comedic influence I think my
brother and I just um loved them so much
what what would be a starter movie would
it be flying Deuces Way Out West what
would you say to people who wanted to
get into them
well they're they're short the music box
that's the classic it could be a great
place great place to start yeah uh and
uh
so you know my parents would say to me
you know we used to watch them when we
were growing up uh-huh and that's a
tough concept to sell too young that's
true especially with comedy
well with anything though I mean yeah I
had the opportunity
to introduce my daughter when she was
like four or five just thank you
McFarland oh yeah what'd you think of
that and I I didn't because I thought it
would just be too confusing that this
this roton middle-aged man
I never got into Spanky McFarland I but
um I for some reason Laurel and Hardy
there was something so accessible about
their company there's something so
universally I think funny about them and
Charlie Chaplin that it was an easy sell
for us because it was also maybe the way
it was delivered um to us it wasn't like
this is what we liked as kids watch this
it was just something we discovered a
little more organically maybe that's
part of the trick yeah it was for me
yeah my parents didn't didn't press any
of this on me I I sought it out and then
what led to the writing Leonard what
what led you to well I wanted to be a
cartoonist but I wasn't very good
and uh like a magazine cartoonist and
the old you know panel cartoons kind of
New Yorkers still Prince
um and uh I went to the library and and
uh consulted a book called Drawing and
selling cartoons and I went out and
bought the right kind of India ink and
yeah yeah the right paper you know you
were all ready yeah I just didn't have
the gift uh perhaps if I had had a
really great teacher
you know who had steered me but I I sent
some of my cartoons to Charles Schultz
oh wow Charles M Schultz and he wrote
back the most
wonderful personal letter encouraging me
and with it a signed original peanuts
daily oh that's so cool dude I tell me
you still have it of course yeah yeah 30
years later I was hired to interview him
on video for a touring Museum show on
one of peanuts anniversaries oh cool wow
so now I'm sitting in his studio in
Santa Rosa California
and I tell them that story
and he jumps out of his chair he says we
got to get you something newer and he
goes and he rifles through some Sunday
page originals and finds one that he
likes and signs it to Alice and me from
Sparky ah which was his nickname to his
friends and family crazy
Sparky wow what a full circle I mean
similar to the one uh I feel like I'm
having with you um what a great full
circle moment that's my whole life is
full of incidents like that yeah I bet I
bet does that then add some pressure
because of course you had to then review
some of his films Charlie Brown there
were some they released some feature
length movies I didn't I didn't review
any of those oh really you just on
principle there was no need yeah yeah
yeah
um but I love I love the the TV shows
yeah me too yeah what what is that like
Leonard to know that you have you're in
proximity to these to these uh directors
and filmmakers and people whose work
you're you're critiquing I've had to
keep an arm's length
it's a very conscious thing
uh Roger Ebert always swore and I have
no reason not to believe him that it
never troubled him
to write Sunday feature pieces for the
for the paper from Chicago uh on people
whose work he was criticizing
sometimes the same day in the same
newspaper
I I I never had uh that you would
separate them yeah
that there have been opportunities where
I could have pursued possible
friendships with directors with
filmmakers and I have I have studiously
avoided that huh because it's just too
awkward right just too awkward and the
one time I violated that
uh not intentionally is the reason I'm
in Gremlins too the new band oh wait a
minute wait a minute was that Joe Dante
yeah uh-huh okay Joe and I knew each
other for as teenagers oh my God I love
Joe talking we went just watch Inner
Space the other night oh that's that's
cool yeah God uh Joe and I we're close
friends but we knew each other yeah and
um
T-Neck
uh well he he he lived uh Southern
Jersey I think okay closer to
Philadelphia uh but we met New York and
uh he was writing capsule reviews uh for
Castle the Frankenstein magazine at the
time and a very good capsule reviews too
so when Gremlins came out I was on this
hot TV show I mean and at that time ET
was red hot yeah the only show of its
kind and I was the movie reviewer that's
right so there wasn't like a second
reviewer as there would be in the
newspaper Entertainment Tonight I just
want to tell people not the movie ET was
also red hot at the time yeah both ETS
but yes that's true well uh uh at a
newspaper I would have recused myself as
they said in the legal profession yes uh
and had the other film critic review of
film by somebody that I I knew uh well
there was no such opportunity so I went
to an early screening of Gremlins and I
found it kind of mean-spirited oh wow
wow I liked all the in-jokes that he
that he put there for his film buff Pals
but I found the film a little mean
Spirit I'm looking up your review of it
now in your in your um God I I have one
from much earlier the one the one that
was my Bible is that it was the yellow
1989 I think it was it's all tattered I
have that in a special place at home but
um I I now I'm curious what you gave and
for people who don't know you had a
rating system of bomb to four stars
right so we'll be talking about some of
those two stars you gave it yeah what
did that feel like then to well it
caused a rift between us which I
completely understand I mean no one no
one likes to be criticized including
including me but not you know uh it's
like saying your baby is ugly
and uh uh so uh we didn't speak for a
while and then a couple years went by
and his then producing partner Mike
Finnell called me one day uh at my
office and said so we're doing Gremlins
too
and we want to have you said why
we want to have the Gremlins invade a TV
network and you know disrupt all the
shows and we want to have a movie review
show we'd like you to be the critic oh
that's funny I said well I think I owe
you that much no oh that's sweet yeah so
there I found myself on a Warner
Brothers Sound Stage oh my God on a set
like a movie theater set
and I was holding a cassette of VHS
cassette in my hand of Gremlins and Joe
said to me just use your own words
so he directed me to give his film a bad
review again in Gremlins to the new
batch until the Gremlins came up behind
me with the strips of 35 millimeter film
and he yanked me backwards and choked me
oh wow that's so great that's that's got
me on two hops gum cards of the story of
the film
that's my ticket to immortality yes for
sure that how meta too and and also um
and and I love what it says about a
friendship and how people um and the ego
and how once that's the the hurt of
something like that subsides you can
find friendship what a great story well
another friend of mine uh uh who
this worked mostly in television but
made a feature and said I would like you
to come to the cast and crew screening I
said I can't do that
he said I'm not inviting you as a Critic
I'm inviting he was my friend I said I
can't pretend that I not to see it you
know as a Critic as well and and what's
more I don't want to be in the midst of
you know your your collaborators yeah
what happens if I don't like it huh and
and very very few filmmakers that I've
met are are philosophical
that way I'll tell you the the best the
best response I ever got was from
Guillermo del Toro who I love for a
variety of reasons and uh came to my
class at USC with uh I think with Pan's
Labyrinth maybe it was even before that
and as I walked him to his car after the
class I said I'm so glad I liked the
movie because otherwise it can be kind
of awkward and he said hey says it's
like a blind date sometimes you wind up
in bed and sometimes it's just a cup of
coffee that's right that's good that's
true that's true and one's not
necessarily better or worse than the
other well there you are it's just how
it it shakes out well is that difficult
and psychologically Leonard tube did you
have that attachment when you were a kid
starting out you you say you were an
indoor kid was being liked um how do you
reconcile that the idea of being like
especially by people who many of whom
you admire and you like what they do
obviously you love films um is that
difficult yes
yeah it's just like that no hedging
around that I mean yeah yes it is it
it's it's uh as I say it's uncomfortable
yeah I mean I try to I I I try to always
call it as I see it you know and and uh
I'm not mean in my reviewing uh and I
was very careful about that on E.T fat a
lot of good it did me I I
early on my uh one of my colleagues was
a wonderful reporter named Genie wolf
and she's covering some event and
Sylvester Stallone was there and she
said she said slack come on over say
something to Entertainment Tonight he
says oh Genie you know I I'd like to
help you but I can't that guy on your
show I don't mind reviews or bad reviews
but he was vicious well this was for the
movie rhinestone which he made with
Dolly Parton and I went universally yeah
well I I went out of my way not to take
any cheap shots yeah him or Dolly and I
said it wasn't their fault if the script
was no good
but oh interesting so but he wrote the
script yeah I was I actually did most of
the writing on that one
well it's funny it must be interesting
when somebody liked that too because
I've encountered this myself has a
sensitivity is is quite sensitive when
it comes to their work well sure well
who yeah again your baby is ugly that's
what it all yeah
uh-huh always boils down to the same
thing you can use you can use uh fancier
words you can yeah yeah uh try to cast
your your criticism and you know and but
it's the babies your babies yeah well
that but sometimes it's unmistakable I
mean and sometimes it's not sometimes
you have to go against the grain of the
of the popular opinion yeah and I would
I would say that that's another
interesting point that Gremlins The
Gremlins situation brings up is that
Gremlins now is a you know a universe
it's beloved it is they show and so is
Gremlins too
yeah yeah you know yeah I got people
still sending me those gum cards
does that ever change does your because
I it's happened to me with certain
movies a Big Lebowski comes to mind
where I remember seeing that for the
first time and thinking I maybe it was
in the wake of Fargo because that had
they had just made cones that just made
that but I didn't quite get Big Lebowski
when it came out it's now one of my
favorite movies upon further reviewing
Step Brothers too does that ever happen
to you is there ever a movie where that
that uh your opinion of a changes over
the course of time well sure uh uh what
I was doing in the book I didn't change
reviews very often because I didn't want
to seem to be flip-flopping you know uh
the two most controversial reviews I
ever wrote in that book were for taxi
driver
and Blade Runner
these are these of which I liked
and and I S and I saw blade runner three
times in a theater every time Ridley
Scott re-edited it I went back and gave
it another shot and I just don't care
for the movie
but uh visually it's you know it it's
it's pretty stunning uh so so I added
that at the end of the review
to acknowledge that I'm aware that it is
you know a high point of production
design and uh all that so but I still
don't don't care for it with taxi driver
I added at the end of that review but
undeniably influential because it is
yeah the last time I interviewed Mr
Scorsese was with Robert De Niro on
stage at the Egyptian Theater here in
Hollywood uh uh when the Irishman came
out I had 45 minutes and I was
determined to cover all nine of the
movies they made together and when I got
to New York New York Marty if I may call
him that turn to the audience and said
in like a stage whisper he doesn't like
that one
he remembered that I didn't like that
what does that feel like I mean just
that that there must be a degree of
power what does that power feel like
when it comes to that um I have no power
I have no power but but just that Martin
Scorsese it's not like it's not like
it's not like being uh let's see drama
critic at the New York Times where I
could you know I can CL I can open or
close the show but no no but but there
is a degree of it I mean like and and to
be influential enough to have made it to
the psyche of Martin Scorsese about one
of his you know he doesn't direct that
many movies and for him to remember one
at your work your work your criticism
what does that feel like in that moment
well at that moment it feels uh it it it
it inflates my ego yeah is aware of me
little me you know
hey everyone not that you asked but I
just watched the movie nope I was really
Blown Away by the whole movie I loved
the movie I love Jordan Peele and one of
the stars of it Keke Palmer has a
hilarious new podcast baby this is Kiki
Palmer it's on Amazon music and You're
Gonna Wanna check it out Kiki has a lot
of burning questions that keep her up at
night for instance remember Tom from
Myspace remember that guy with a smile
in that little white T-shirt Tom what
what happened to him Kiki Wonders that
it keeps her up and um she attempts to
answer that she's putting friends family
in some of the hottest experts to ask
them the real questions we want to know
like how has dating changed in the
digital age where would former child
stars be if they weren't actors these
are the questions running through Kiki's
mind and she's letting us all in on it
because on baby this is Kiki Palmer no
topic is off limits Prime members listen
to the Amazon music exclusive podcast
baby this is Kiki Palmer in the Amazon
music app download the app today it's
hard to imagine losing a loved one a
wife a husband a child for many it is
their biggest fear from wondering the
vanished is a podcast that covers the
stories of often overlooked and unsolved
missing persons cases every week host
Marissa Jones dives into a new case
sharing the details of their mysterious
disappearance from interviews with
family friends law enforcement and even
suspects in an effort to reveal the
truth the vanished has even aided in
getting long overdue arrests through
their in-depth interviews Marissa
reminds listeners of the human behind
the headline and aims to help family
members find their vanished loved one or
at least a sense of Peace follow the
vanished wherever you get your podcasts
you can listen ad free on the Amazon
music or wondery app
[Music]
if there's not a re-release of something
are you ever tempted to go back and
re-examine it uh in one of your books
kind of re
um if you've reconnected with a movie
let's say over time because people
change over time and so I imagine
they're well yes
we change and the world changes
the context of every movie changes with
the passing of the of the years and uh
uh you know something that seemed
Cutting Edge you know at a given moment
in time May no longer
I have that uh that you know that asset
I bet like do you do you recall your
experience with um we just saw the Texas
Chainsaw Massacre out and hadn't seen
that in a long time and I looked up your
review and you you gave it three stars
and said um talked about how influential
it was
um but I imagine when a movie like that
comes out it is it's so jarring only
because it is so different
um do you recall your experience with a
movie like that for example I can't
watch those movies oh oh interesting no
kidding I have no stomach for graphic
horror movies
I was raised on the gothic horror movies
of the universal from the 30s uh right
like Hammer Horrors Frankenstein Dracula
the mummy The Wolf Man uh uh all of that
and uh so that was my idea of a horror
movie
and uh I uh
when I went to see Friday the 13th part
seven
part seven wait wait don't tell me which
one that is that's after I couldn't
Jason's already taken Manhattan oh you
can okay because I used to love that
about you because you would review uh or
in your books there would be reviews of
all of the ones that were probably
deemed schlockier lesser to other
critics but I I love that about and I've
talked to other people who gravitated
toward your books for that reason too
that you gave them all um consideration
Friday the 13th four
um or nightmare Elm Streets you know all
of those movies I sat there and I
realized what the difference was between
me and the younger people sitting around
me in the theater which was that I took
it seriously oh oh you didn't see the
the yeah the humor when the asks you
know split someone's skull I I'm taking
it seriously and the other the other
people in the theater take him as a goof
ah yeah yeah for them it's escapism but
the classics like the Exorcist or psycho
I imagine oh yeah yeah yeah
um The Exorcist though uh which we just
saw last night is
unbelievably
um graphic and frightening and that's
the scariest movie I've ever seen really
I I believe that but it's not just not
just scary the unease that it engenders
from the very start from the beginning
when they start playing Tubular Bells
you know and that soundtrack that hum on
that soundtrack uh right away you're
you're feeling queasy yes it's it's
unset you're right right off the bat
just the score the sound is so
unsettling that's what Kate said about
um my girlfriend said about Texas
Chainsaw Massacre is that it's it's it's
not so much and you say this in your
view whether or not that that was you
but it's in your book that um it was
there's a surprising lack of gratuitous
agor and violence in that it's um it's
what you don't see and there's something
just disturbing about it it's not so
much yes shock it's just really
disturbing yeah my favorite movie I
think the best if I if I were to if I
could keep my desert island movie I
think would be back to the future
um and which is obviously a classic
people love it you gave it three stars
you gave the sequel two and a half and
the third one three and a half
I'm so curious about that because I I
don't know that I've ever one other
person I talked to Preferred the third
one to the first one I would give I I
would revise that review of the original
now
and give it a higher rating interesting
just how it survived over time yes it's
a terrific movie and it's become part of
the cultural landscape and uh uh you
know it's it's it's all it's it's it's
critic proof yeah that's so funny I was
gonna hold your feet to the fire and I
didn't I realize it'd be that easy
but what what does that feel like
because I know there's now an Infamous
review and I think it's the LA Times
gave it a bad review something like Back
to the Future is it does it take a
degree of Courage I imagine it does to
to review something that um that that
maybe many of your colleagues are are to
go against the grain of this particular
like always always I bet whether it's
Pro or con yeah yeah sure in either
direction it it can be very awkward and
uh and especially I was on a pop TV show
for so many years uh so it's not like I
was talking to a uh the Intelligentsia
you know or uh you know a uh a niche
audience
uh so yeah I remember when Romancing the
Stone came out and people were loving it
I said it's okay yeah yes yes yeah and
and two is there any pressure from let's
say at the Time Entertainment Tonight to
um not push no no no they were no they
were very good about that they were very
very good about that yeah and and what
emboldens them to grant you that
Authority I mean how did that how did a
role like that come about well the
show's success I think yeah gave him
that that uh that privilege although
uh this is ancient history now they took
me off the movie review beat after they
lost an interview opportunity with
Barbra Streisand because of my review
for film Yentl oh my God oh my God
really and and oh and her publicist
never let me forget it no it never let
me forget it he kept beating me on the
head every time I would see him but
somebody as massive as Barbra Streisand
you just think yeah you take the slings
and the arrows uh along with all the all
the good stuff at two and a half Stars
you didn't give it that better of you
that's amazing a two and a half star
review she she took it no no it was the
version that I that I aired on
that I read on Entertainment Tonight oh
my God that's wild well at that point
they said well and again I will work for
succession of producers but the producer
at that time decided Well maybe we can't
afford to be giving bad reviews to
people we're courting when you went from
being a writer being behind the desk to
to an on-camera personality what was
that transition like was was there a
little bit of a learning curve there or
did you take to it pretty naturally well
I I took to it in their eyes
they aired my audition tape now looking
back at it I think I'm terribly stiff
and uh but I got away with it because I
was reading my own words yeah I bet
yeah and uh I think that's what got me
through yeah it was organic the idea of
writing for the ear
and not for the eye it took me a long
time to really uh get that down and and
and talking to an individual in the
audience instead of just talking to a
camera what do you think in your opinion
is is the easiest way to ruin a movie I
mean I I I'm I often wonder this when
I'm watching when I take a movie in and
I I formulate an opinion of it uh I I
tend to gravitate more toward I I notice
first the acting I I noticed the acting
um maybe just because I am an actor at
something I love but in your opinion
what's the easiest way to ruin an
otherwise good movie is it the writing
that the directing what what where does
what's the seed
well miscasting oh yeah yeah not the
actor's fault but if you if the director
hasn't cast it properly right or what we
think of us properly
you know Godfather Three comes to mind
uh I I just read your Sophia Coppola
yeah
um who of course is an incredible
director has become a very gifted
filmmaker but she was not an actress and
it showed and it hurt that movie I think
it was supposed to be Winona Winona
Ryder yeah yeah when you do read another
person's review is it just out of
security curiosity about how uh you know
another movie is being received did you
just get curious as a Critic
when I read a review it's after I've
seen the movie
it's what I'm looking for is a good
essay I'm looking for good writing
and I'm looking for somebody who maybe
illuminate
things about the movie that I didn't
pick up on oh yeah who do you enjoy
reading were you a Roger Ebert fan when
I knew Gene and Roger it was from their
television show like millions of other
people watched them on their TV show but
it was before the internet came along
and Roger posted all his reviews online
which which his his wife Chaz maintains
that sight huh uh uh so I never read him
he wasn't carried in my local newspaper
and he wasn't carried out here in the LA
Times when he moved to this Coast
he's a wonderful writer yeah he is oh
man really wonderful writer yeah and he
manages to make his reviews personal
but in a way that doesn't put you off
would you ever read uh some of his work
for example and and rethink
your own criticism of a movie
well I I read this criticism and I'm
jealous that I can't do what he did so
so seemingly so easily uh calling on uh
events from his life I read Anthony Lane
in the New Yorker and I read Todd
McCarthy who was with variety for almost
40 years yes I love to yes I say I love
Tom McCarthy because he's given me good
good reviews well he's a Critic I
actually rely on I I trust his opinion I
like Owen gliberman who's now me too
Entertainment Weekly yeah me too I like
going I stopped reading reviews at a
certain point just because my skin was
way too thin I remember reading one I
remember almost word for word which she
said about
um my appearance why is that your
reviews never seemed snarky or
mean-spirited to me um well I here's
here's here's a a situation a very
specific situation whatever it is now
seven or eight years ago I went to
usually my wife comes with me because
she loves watching we like watching them
together I hope so yes well we've been
married 40 you know 47 years wow good
for you wow is that did you go on a date
is that how you did were movies part of
your early courtship
two silent movies yeah wow
any woman that would sit through two
silent movies has to be paid attention
to right
uh so uh and and if not my wife and my
daughter would come with me before she
was married had her own life uh but I I
went by myself to see a a preview
screening a press screening of Zoolander
2.
now I'd seen Zoolander thought it was
pretty funny not a great movie but
pretty funny so I had no reason to
expect Zoolander 2 to be anything but
more of that yeah and I sat there
and this movie just pissed me off
and uh and I'm sitting there and I'm
thinking why am I sitting here Aha and
there is there is a cert I never walk
out of movies
I I don't hold myself to the same uh
demand at home
if I streaming is easier to walk out of
a movie at home
yeah easier to pull the disc out of the
machine yeah walk into the living
Channel yeah walk into the kitchen yeah
but if I've gone to a screening or if
I've gone to the local Multiplex
I stay uh-huh
but in this case I'm sitting there and
I'm getting more and more annoyed at
this movie and after 25 minutes I
finally said that's it I'm out of here
I'm gone
uh because
at a certain point
it becomes masochistic oh no I didn't I
didn't want I didn't want to surrender
to that so I went home and went right to
my computer and typed this headline why
I walked out of Zoolander too oh boy
and that was the review that I that I
wrote I couldn't review the movie I I
hadn't seen in its entirety but I could
review the first 25 minutes and say why
it got me so uh you know riled up yeah
yeah I now I feel like I'm struggling
with whether or not we should leave this
in I think we should because it's really
funny and interesting but um personally
just because Ben is a a pal and he's
sort of a mentor and
um he we've been circulating there's
been talk of doing Dodgeball 2 and I had
been on the show and we talked about and
um we talked about that Vince Vaughn is
a good idea for the for a sequel and and
I think the reason Ben is uh hesitant to
do it is is because of his experience
with Zoolander too so um selfishly I'm
tempted to cut this out because I would
like to do dodgeball too I don't want to
add any more fuel to that but I
understand I understand it is
interesting and you're right I mean it
must be um and Zoolander is a is a great
movie so you go in expecting well at
least something
funny and enjoyable you know on par with
that and I've seen I try to do sequels
better than I noticed Bill and Ted's
Excellent Adventure um you get the Bogus
Journey a better review than this so
you're I know that you're not precious
about that stuff and you're very fair
with sequels I try to take each each
movie on its own terms just yeah it was
yeah you know if it's if it's supposed
to be a silly comedy be a good silly
comedy you know yeah I don't I don't go
expecting King Lear if what you're
offering me is Bill and Ted's Bogus
Journey you know I see I see you're
conditioned already to expect a certain
thing yeah are there um are there movies
that your family or friends or people
that you trust uh are very incredulous
about why you gave it a good or bad
review do you ever butt heads with
friends or colleague family members oh
well sure I mean everybody talks about
movies that's that's the thing about
movies the president of the United
States watches movies and the guy who
take picks up your garbage watches
movies everybody watches movies and and
uh and everybody has an opinion that's
true uh yes Reggie a point of a little
bragging moment I remember going to the
White House this Obama's right-hand man
she was showing me around and he was a
great guy and he said but he said by the
way man I gotta tell you I love Jeepers
Creepers which is this the horror movie
that I did years ago and and I said God
you saw that how crazy he goes you know
who else saw it and he pointed to the
the office the White House the seat uh
White House oval offici
um and so I think about that all the
time very selfishly
um when I think about it why not why not
no
um too much to ask you I know we're
running out of time I'm curious though
what you think of the future of movies
we talked about being in a movie theater
and there's something about you would
just mentioned it's easier to walk out
obviously when you're home
um how important is that experience is
to to be in a movie theater with an
audience how crucial a component is that
um to the movie experience for you I
think it's pretty important I don't
prefer watching movies at home it's my
last resort
uh during the pandemic it was you know
pretty much the only option right but uh
I'm trying not to be lazy yeah now
that's that's a real challenge it's
gotten so easy to stay home yes I know
right you know it's it's all right there
everything about it is comfortable and
relaxed and I never go to movie theaters
on weekends never never oh interesting I
I want to have other people there but
I'd rather not be a mob yeah I bet I
know it makes sense
and Leonard what do you think of all the
Marvel movies because that's that's
become I mean when you talk about
theater experiences now I can't I can't
generalize because you know like I love
the Ant-Man movies they've done two so
far and I really like the concept and
the execution I think they're clever and
funny yeah Peyton Reed and uh you know a
sense of humor is very important to me
in those films yes although although the
most recent Thor was playing it for
laughs and I didn't like that yes it was
leaning too heavily into it that's
interesting yeah well it's interesting
because you say that about uh you have a
real playfulness
um I've listened to your podcast your
reviews have always had a little bit of
a there's a charm in that and I noticed
you said that about Texas Chainsaw
Massacre the original as opposed to the
the Remake um was that the Remake had no
um it wasn't leavened I think you used
the word leavened by a sense of play or
humor yeah it's why I have trouble with
Christopher Nolan's work oh yes this is
there's no sense of humor uh yeah
interesting not and and how much of your
they say We Are Who We Are by the time
we're seven was that when you cultivated
obviously a love of movies and you were
watching TV was it most well I was
watching Laurel and Hardy right I was
watching The Little Rascals yeah you
know I was watching a Porky Pig you know
I I you know I was conditioned by the
best yeah Chuck Chuck Jones I love so
much um do people ever stop you in the
street and and you know we talked about
famous people who who maybe were aware
of your work but does that happen to you
on a daily basis as you walk through
life people stopping you and saying hey
by the way just casually wanting to
discuss movies it used to happen more
when I was on this really
wildly popular TV show yeah but it does
still happen actually in the Heyday of
my movie guide within one week's time I
swear this this really happened one guy
stopped is in New York anybody will
buttonhole you uh and Ella you're
worried that there's going to be an Uzi
you know involved somehow but in New
York one guy stopped me said you know
how I know if I'm gonna like a movie I
said no how he said I take your rating
and I double it oh and within days
another guy stopped me and said you know
how I figure out if I'm gonna enjoy a
movie I said how he said I take your
writing and I cut it in half isn't that
funny isn't that funny so so you know
yeah go figure can't please everyone no
do do do do do do do do
hello hello again
[Music]
what is your favorite emoji Mr Mall uh
if you use emojis I don't okay
yeah anytime even like an old school a
colon and a parenthesis
no
sorry to be a washout no not at all it's
um it's we're trying to appeal to a
younger crowd by that with that question
and it's just a Shameless appeal just
pandering uh um what is uh what do you
think is more lit
um Tick Tock no I don't know I'm just
gonna ask you another
Millennial question who was your first
celebrity crush
oh gosh who was my first celebrity crush
minutes thinking that but I'm really bad
at this ah oh well well Thelma Todd
Thelma Todd dead 85 years but still my
uh but not in your heart not in my heart
he lives she lives on
um what is your favorite ice cream
flavor Leonard chocolate oh wow you know
what's amazing we've been doing this
question now for about two years which
is also amazing uh but that that is a
question for grown-ups to answer but I
don't I don't think anyone's ever said
that with such conviction too
oh well for me it's easy
easy chocolate okay uh and your favorite
holiday then Thanksgiving you get
together with family does Jesse have
kids do you have grandkids [ __ ] I we
have our first grandchild 11 months old
oh good for you adorable yeah adorable
yeah I bet um good for you and she lives
with us oh no kidding
get to see her every single day Ah
that's great spend quality time oh
that's great happy for you
um and this oh look at her oh how cute
oh my God she's adorable Leonard's
showing me a picture they're really cute
um yes and now I'm thinking about uh uh
what you said about calling people's
babies ugly and I thought how hurtful
and awful that would be
um yeah and you're lucky that I I'm not
even tempted to because she's so
objectively adorable
um this might be hard for you to answer
but we ask everyone what is an acclaimed
movie that you're embarrassed to admit
you haven't seen so a movie that you
know maybe people shame you for not
having seen oh
um well those all those horror movies
right you know right people talk about
midsomar and and uh Jesse said oh no
you'd have trouble with this so much oh
yeah hereditary I already asked yeah I
love those yeah uh uh and what is a what
is a game show past or present I'm
wondering if you've been on Celebrity
Jeopardy or something like that that you
would like to be on
oh
I'd like to be on Jeopardy but I'd be
too embarrassed and I said I foul it up
yeah yeah I was on the ten thousand
dollar pyramid oh yeah and password plus
those were my my two uh uh
outings in the game show field yeah oh
oh yeah those are a little less um
there's a little less pressure only
because Jeopardy is you know it's
knowledge it's your your an academic so
it'd probably be
um difficult to lose that one uh and do
you drink coffee or tea and if so how do
you take it
herbal tea herbal tea
with uh one teaspoon of honey oh very
nice um I've never I've never been a
coffee drinker my wife my wife functions
on coffee that's it see that function
without it that's amazing we had Ali
Wentworth her husband's George
Stephanopoulos and they have the same
Dynamic she has never ever tried coffee
never everyone I've talked to who was a
coffee drinker says they started
drinking it when they pulled an
all-nighter during final exams from
college
I never did that because I never cared
enough about my my grades oh interesting
wow that's interesting why it wasn't
because you just already knew what you
it wasn't a stepping stone College you
just knew it yeah no no I I mean it's
not that I could Ace the exam because I
didn't yeah but uh I just was not
motivated I was already doing what I was
going to do with my life right right
right because you started so early wow
um and uh do you enjoy cereal do you
ever enjoy cereal I'm a big cereal guy
oh I I mix cereals oh interesting what
is your what are your go-to
um
uh
Honey Nut Cheerios
uh
cinnamon grams oh cinnamon grams
yes I love cinnamon Quaker Quaker Quaker
uh this little square the squares the
O's the Quaker Oat Square the Quaker Oat
Squares yeah little touch of brown sugar
yeah right the best yes
um if you had a sandwich if you could
choose a different first name Leonard is
a respectable uh name but but if you had
had to choose a different one when I was
a kid I wanted to be Jerry Jerry was a
cool man oh Cherry yeah
Sherry Moulton
um and if he had a sandwich named after
you uh the Leonard Malton sandwich at a
fancy Deli at canners or something what
would be on it
rare roast beef hmm and uh
maybe provolone cheese okay and tomato
and and on what type of bread
uh
foreign
Jewish rye Jewish rye
um Roy that's I'm trying to I tried to
do a joke I tried to do a Jewish rye
would also be called I'm trying to
combine oi and rye and it didn't work
I'm gonna I'll Workshop that one is this
the slowest lightning round you've ever
had no no no it's actually quite uh
surprisingly it's um pretty Up Tempo
um but we've had much slower ones what
is your favorite Tom Hanks movie if you
could pick one Tom Hanks movie to show
your new uh grandchild for example
uh well the first one I probably show
her would be Splash yeah yeah
have you seen that in a while
no yeah it's interesting to see that was
when sometimes I watch movies from that
area which is my I'm sure everyone says
this about the era they grew up in it's
my favorite era for movies
um and you watch them years later and
some you know sometimes they don't age
as they age in a different way
um yeah it still has it's so cheap yeah
it's like an act an actor's story yeah
we we were friendly for for a while with
a character actor who worked a lot named
Richard B Shull
s-h-u-l-l okay you know his face
he they they shot a a lot of Splash in
Canada I think in Toronto
not Vancouver but Toronto if I'm
remembering the story right
and he shows up on the set one day and
the director says
no Richard Shaw
s-c-h-a-a-l they hired the wrong actor
no my gut for Splash that was for Splash
yeah yeah oh my god
um that's Ron Howard yeah full circle in
our in our talk today
um I hope he didn't say it to his face
well yes oh my God it's a good thing
exclaim he exclaimed on the set oh my
God it could have been it could have
been Robert Shaw I guess certain actors
you wouldn't because Richard shell told
me the story so oh my God that's funny
Would you rather take a time machine to
the past or the Future Past yes and an
era that you would want to uh relive
well it's hard to say because the 1930s
are my favorite movie decade huh after
the 1970s yeah which which I experienced
but the 1930s were a terrible decade
yeah depression sure you know so third
right yeah the irony is that out of this
misery came so many great movies yes
that's true it is it must be very hard
for you to do a top three list like
three like does your Desert Island
movies Casablanca okay which is my
number one huh yeah always and and which
I saw for the first time in a theater oh
wow how cool not on TV how could it was
a bogart Revival in the late 60s the
counterculture movement adopted bogey is
their anti-hero right I'm thinking about
that Woody Allen movie played against
Sam
where he becomes his he's kind of like
his ghostly Mentor yeah I saw them I saw
what he do that on Broadway oh really
wow yeah wow that's great one of the few
movies he didn't direct that he started
that's right yeah that's right
um so that would be it would be that one
and Singing in the Rain
and uh Dumbo Dumbo wow okay not the Tim
Burton remake not the timber okay yeah I
know I don't need to qualify that yes
yes which you did with a lot of um ve
eminence
uh yeah what about Laurel I'm curious
about because we share a love of Laurel
and Hardy what what feature of theirs
would you sons of the desert oh sons of
the desert yes I love Sunset I you know
if you're ever in there's a small town
and you have to look it up in Georgia
yes I shot a movie in Arkansas I was
driving through
the most random uh highway sign at the
next exit it's the Oliver Hardy it's the
Laurel and Hardy Museum in um if you
ever get if you're ever out that way
it's it's between Athens and Atlanta I
believe um wow it's so such a trip
because it's in this one Horse Town off
the highway in Georgia but it's where
Oliver Hardy was born I guess and so
they have so much great so many
artifacts from Sons you would love it
there are Sun's the desert
um yeah it'd be right up here I think
mine would be Way Out West uh I love
that in flying juices
just I formed the first sanctioned
Junior tent of Sons of the desert oh wow
that was 13. wow and it was the Tit for
Tat tent of T-Neck oh that's great
that's great well you you've you've
bested me in our Laurel and Hardy fandom
um and uh Leonard toilet roll over or
under do you have a preference over over
yes yes without um that's how it was
patented oh really I learned that a year
ago from somebody that uh uh in the
patent oh wow application it shows over
oh my gosh you know maybe we can retire
this question now because people almost
I think 90 say over some are very
convicted about it being under
surprisingly uh Quest love I think most
recently but
um I think maybe now we can retire at
this because we now know there's a
definitive way to do it well I hope
that's the source I'll check it out I'll
fact check it
um and if you would please Leonard
finish this sentence life is sure word
so
have a good time yes well this has been
such a such a clear example of that such
a good time uh thank you and and I I
mean I know I do this to you every time
I see you but I thank you for all of
your your work and and your kindness to
me uh over the years I I I'd love to
keep doing this
anytime you sit oh it's the best anytime
you're bored just I will no anytime
you're bored
um I'll be there uh and so thanks and my
best to Jesse congrats to thank you
thank you very much yeah um thank you
thanks Leonard good to be with you
[Music]
so that just happened so that just
happened he has a certain Panache yes he
sure does he's like an old timey he's
like a he's like an old gentleman yes
like a little Tom Snyder from remember
Tom Snyder oh yeah yeah I like Tom
Snyder yes you have a Tom Snyder I
thought you might say that
I feel a little like Tom Snyder might
feel by the way
um speaking of you and people you remind
me of H John Benjamin I was re-listening
to the episode that we did with him the
uh I played it for Kate the diarrhea
story great story it's so good but then
I started watching Nathan for you oh I I
I don't know where I've been I didn't
write it on the show uh Nathan uh Nathan
I would love God he's a genius yeah he's
brilliant this I I the stuff he does on
that show you never saw it no and so
many people have said to me yo I'm sure
they've assumed I've watched Nathan
people say yo yeah yeah people are like
yeah is that what I said I thought
that's what I heard anyway Leonard yeah
he's reviewed a lot of funny things he
has yeah things that you've been in and
things you haven't been in yeah what did
you think you know the thing that struck
me was that I always used to love
reading his reviews of like R-rated like
horror movies and you know movies with
sex and stuff and um and if you were
titillated by those reviews just the
mention of nudity dilated me um I
remember he used to write about like you
know so Angie Dickinson or Bo Derek or
whatever and um he would just mention
that there was nudity in a movie and and
it was that was enough for you it's
exciting to me it was a low bar yeah I
know well when you're that age I know it
doesn't take much a stiff breeze it
reminded me that I have never seen
singing in the rain in one of his
favorite movies oh I don't either and I
it just always seemed like something I
wouldn't like you know but I I looked it
up at a like incredible review people
love it it's a it's a classic and I you
know why I've always been a little
turned off by it I I've never well to
the point where I've never sat down and
actually tried to watch it even knowing
that it's like so beloved I know because
it's um it's in the title it's like I
don't know if I want to watch something
in the rain for that long and you see
whenever you see clips for a minute and
in the rain I mean it's fun but I do
like how much he likes uh Laurel and
Hardy yeah I know he loves yeah loves
and they mean I thought that was good
good advice that if you were to
recommend one short music box I would
say that too because there's something
so Timeless about that and it's so
simple you know yeah it's Sisyphus it's
just yeah it's just these two guys
trying to get to deliver a piano to
someone's house it's and all the things
that could go like if you made that now
yeah it would be a little different only
because you know vehicles are different
and technology is different but it but
it would be the same type of funny
things would happen I'm sure I know I
was yeah simple Timeless and trying to
solve a problem and not being able to I
was thinking about some of the movies
that I really miss and love and you know
we've been watching these horror movies
and just saw Halloween uh and it's it's
original the original and it's just a
guy
stalking somebody it is so simple and
then I had seen a couple days earlier
the new David Gordon green Halloween
there's just so much story now because
there's been so many movies and like so
there's such depth to the lore I guess
but there's something about that
original that was just so simple and
that's what made it scary it was just
you don't really see Michael Myers a lot
it's just kind of like the back of his
head and and his point of view like that
was scary yeah the breathing that's
scary yeah it's not seeing a mysterious
I know that's why the beginning of
Jeepers Creepers not to bring it back to
you please um is scarier than the end of
Jeepers Creepers in my opinion yep once
I know it's the anticipation of like who
is this guy and then who's driving this
truck I know and then when you see him
it's like oh oh I guess that's kind of
weird looking it's scary in a different
way but to me it's not as scary as the
anticipation
um Leonard Moulton yes Leonard Martin
looks like pod doesn't he I mean you
didn't see him but he does wait did he
in his bomb reviews
a friend of ours
a friend a friend of our an
ex-girlfriend of our friends would say
bomb.com
oh yes yes yeah those burgers are bomb I
don't know who you were talking about
yeah oh okay
um but did he have speaking of bombs did
he have in his reviews were his bombs a
little picture of a Turkey
um
that was another book I had okay it
wasn't Leonard Malden maybe it was
eventually I had I broke with turkeys in
it because I
no I think I I I his the one the
original the yellow one had it just said
bomb okay okay because I remember I know
what you're talking about my Pro my
biggest problem with Leonard Moulton as
a kid was that he gave Howard the Duck a
bomb oh yeah I hate it I did and I loved
it I thought it was so good well that
was also like a little kid so people
loved Howard the dog I loved it and he
gave it a bomb well but other than that
I tended to agree with him a lot he gave
some good movies movies that I love like
Police Academy he didn't like Gremlins
no I know I know but I like that he um
horror movies in general he doesn't like
he can't handle well I remember saying
the question how are so many of these
horror movies reviewed by him well he
yeah I guess he farmed it out to people
that he trusted and um and now his
daughter reviews I think a lot of them
because she loves horror movies okay but
as a kid I just I was like how is he
have time to watch
um because he reviews everything every
and back then it was like now everything
comes out on streaming and for the most
part and but back then there was a thing
they were called straight to video where
it was there was a movie theater movies
and then all the movies B movies would
go just they'd say straight to video and
um he would review all of those which
was rare for like a major film critic
but I guess looking back if he he wasn't
reviewing a lot of them but he well he
also I think he did watch a lot of
movies because yeah he did refer to
himself his childhood as um as being an
indoor kid he said he was and I picture
it immediately what did you picture when
he said that pie no I picture the k
cable guy as a kid oh that's funny
sitting two inches away from the screen
she's like I have no aptitude for sports
yeah Mommy will be back soon just sit
there and didn't make you think like if
he had shown the slightest ability or
interest in soccer let's say yeah he
might have had an entirely different
life well but he just stayed inside and
watched TV and watched movies well and
then look what happened yeah yeah no it
worked out so I know but but for the I
know what you mean like if a kid were
doing that I would be worried yeah it
seems like they wouldn't develop any
sort of social skills and he clearly has
developed that he's extremely Charming
or do you learn it like the Cable Guy
did from uh well you know from I know
what you're saying I don't maybe uh and
Leonard Mountain has this kind of like
old fashioned if you watch those old
days
well like that he loves Casablanca yes
yeah fetishize is probably Bogart and
how to be I mean we all learn how to be
cool for I at least I did from cool
people in movies I I
like emulated Michael J fox yeah who by
the way hasn't texted me back you went
in too strong I know you got too
aggressive I know you're too eager
I'm planning another you have to treat
him like a little squirrel you just have
to like
you've been you've been with Maggie too
long thank you they're like feeding
squirrels apples what if she gets bit
then it's a problem for me yeah because
you'll have to I'll have to drive her to
the hospital to get like rabies shots in
her stomach yeah um that's where you get
them in the stuff I think so yeah I know
boy here's a letter from Deborah Rook
subject paleontologist nerd big fan
great I'd love to hang out with a
paleontologist nerd I thought you'd say
a big fan
oh no too mostly a nerd uh the big fan
might be get uncomfortable okay Dear
Justin and Christian I have literally
been staying up at night thinking and
crafting this email it is calming since
it comes out in Justin's voice oh that's
nice but I feel like I should just get
it sent so I can get some sleep yes I'm
she ended up doing that so hopefully she
got to sleep first off Justin man I
completely adore you and have since
Galaxy Quest oh thank you Deborah I
really connected with that character and
thought you were downright dreamy oh
thanks Deborah my sister who's the
youngest I am the oldest and and I love
accepted and when I got rid of all my
DVDs
um but I don't have anything to play
them anymore not even my computer she
grabbed that one the fastest and I
absolutely love the dynamic you and
Christian have
thanks Deborah the podcast always makes
me smile even when things are even when
things are or what it doesn't say
there's there's a it doesn't say even
when things are uh can we it's like
choose right I think so maybe yeah
um less than great Melancholy yeah okay
uh anywho okay anywho I wanted to write
about something amusing I have noted in
your lightning round you've been asking
if you'd rather go into the past or the
future this is fun but it strikes me
every time that no one ever wants to go
really far into the past not even like
BC I'm a paleont it's funny we were just
talking about this
um
it's so loud it's so it's a loud rapper
on the smarties and what do you did you
suck on them yeah yeah
um yeah I bite them with my two front
teeth you look so excited to get it in
your mouth I do I it's one of the only
things I I chew with just my front teeth
I find it so pleasurable
is it kind of chalky yeah Deborah says I
am a paleontologist by training cool
currently working in professional
learning of biology faculty at
universities so I am always shocked when
no one wants to go see dinosaurs or
something yes I get it Deborah I studied
early cenozoic mammals cenozoic wow cool
mammals so I would always want to go
back and write a she's just showing off
now glyptodont and then she says glypto
daunt think giant furry armadillo oh I
think I've seen those or uh tinyodont
you'll have to Google these are what I
studied during my masters ateneodont and
if you ever have any paleo related
questions I am so your gal I may not
have any gradual working dinosaurs but I
do have two kids and sometimes host
events as a token paleontologist so
that's basically the same level of
training for dinosaurs yeah kids know a
lot about dinosaurs this brings me to my
prehistorical would you rather would you
rather go to the Triassic and see the
beginnings of many groups of animals we
know and love like dinosaurs birds which
are dinosaurs but also evolved in the
Triassic and mammals Oracle back to the
Paleo Gene which is right after the
non-avian dinosaurs died out to see what
survived to start the age of mammals AKA
now I know my answer but since this
topic is not often broached on the show
I'm not sure I have heard y'all talk
about it at all but I haven't gotten to
all the episodes yet I came in late I am
really interested in what you think oh
that's a good okay let's see so would
you rather go back to the Triassic um to
see the beginnings of groups like
dinosaurs birds uh and mammals or go
back to the Paleo Gene right after the
non-avian dinosaurs died out
isn't one option just further back well
yeah that's obvious but they're they're
not at the same time they're two
different time periods but isn't one
option like what we have now basically
what we have now the beginnings of what
what turned out to be what survived yeah
but that's a that's right but why would
you say well I guess what I'm saying is
why would you choose that one if it's a
version of what we have now would you
would rather see the big dinosaurs I
know what she's saying I I think there's
an argument that can be made for the
Paleo Gene period because you get to see
like that like the animal she studied
the the tinyodont or the um the other
one the the basically the furry
armadillo that the glyptodont okay to
see like how that we we'd we'd be more
familiar with those shapes and those
types uh in our animals today there'd be
like you know there's a whole group of
um
they called them uh megafauna in in
Australia for example that that died out
around the same time man humans landed
there the megafauna were like giant
koala bears giant uh kangaroos scary
well no because they were actually also
are you in this hypothetical are you
safe or can you just go and it's
unprotected humans were safe from them
because they they hadn't uh they didn't
have the pre they didn't realize them
they recognized them as Predators uh
have you ever seen Jurassic Park well
these were like these were like
basically like a like a large bunny or
like you know a large koala they killed
them large armadillo I mean like they
were met they were giant you know
tortoises and anyways I would like to
see both but I think I think I would be
more it's more exotic to see the
Triassic something that is completely
unfamiliar you know to see a huge
dinosaur I know it would be incredible
whereas no like versions of mammals we
have now yeah okay cool well but I
wouldn't be as excited about it if if as
long as I'm safe well that's the thing
if you had to take care of your safety
if you had to like it was safety was
involved I'm picturing Joe Mazzello in
Jurassic Park you would be joking yeah
yeah
um yeah I can see an older Harry or Joe
Mazzella yeah well probably he's
probably your age now yeah
um I I you know what it's the amazing
thing about Jurassic Park the movie is
that there's a part of me that feels
like I've already seen a lot of those
animals just from watching that movie
wow to see them in person obviously but
be amazing but also can you remember the
theme song right now
can you do Indiana Jones right now
oh [ __ ] um
Superman
Back to the Future
oh [ __ ] you have this look like you're
about to go down you're like um
wait
people are good we're gonna get speaking
of reviews we're gonna get some Stellar
reviews for this one uh
uh yeah I would I would go I don't want
to see the big dinosaurs I think I might
want to see the mammals wow how they
look it would be less scary too anyway
um but great question you know they've
been trying to clone they can they this
is crazy that they can do this now clone
um woolly mammoth
wow there's a whole
um there's a whole group of people that
are like uh doing that going like trying
to do this like I think and I think they
have the ability to do it I think
they're gonna try crazy that's a very
loose interpretation of uh
probably a really complicated issue
um back to Deborah thanks so much for uh
such a fun show and all the smiles it
has given me uh thank you Deborah and
now hopefully I will sleep soundly
tonight I hope so love Dr Debbie Debbie
you don't mean a lot of babies named
Debbie anymore Deb I like that I like
the old Deborah
um thank you Debbie Dr Debbie that was
yeah good question good question um and
if you guys would like to write into the
show we love getting these letters our
email address is life is short at
wondery.com yes and uh thank you to the
great my childhood
um Crush yeah kind of really
um the the great Leonard Mountain he was
so kind to spend so much time with me
and um and he's always been a kind
reviewer I've noticed and he said that
yeah he said I'm not me I don't like
hurting people yeah anyway thank you to
the great Leonard Moulton and to
everyone listening hopefully you can
you'll listen to us next week as well
please we didn't turn you off with the
uh I think I think people like that
that's a fun game it is fun it's tough
yeah
um that is a tough one but it's you're
supposed to do like the five you know
like the classic John Williams yeah and
just see if you can effortlessly go
that's that's not one of them in the
game it's Star Wars The Godfather
[Music]
oh no no that's so that's the Last of
the Mohicans um
[Music]
oh my God all right well okay well we'll
figure it out let's say goodbye to
everybody okay
um and Mish maybe on the the the music
going out we can do this
foreign what yeah
[Music]
I don't remember this
oh yeah
is that it yes
wow good that's a hard one to remember
yeah
there we go
thank you for listening to life is short
life is short it's life is short is
hosted by me
Justin long and it is co-hosted by my
consigliere Christian long it's produced
by him as well it's also produced by
Megan Monaco and Katie Allen senior
producers Michelle Mish Lambs audio
engineer Sergio Enriquez and with an
executive producer his name is Marshall
Marshall Louie he made me an offer I
couldn't refuse to do this show and do
it with the company never never go
against the family never can go against
wondering the company we do it for thank
you that's a little too late I know I
know yeah
I was just kind of like oh okay bye I'll
work on it and I'll do it again all next
week thank you bye
you know also also let's say you are I
think about having to fill out those
forms that's why I think people with
hyphenated names no I do too and I think
it's selfish for the parents do what's
the name Juju they each need their name
I know the last name I know pick one or
like combine them into one or something
but two names for the rest of that kid's
life you know every form he fills out or
signature he signs it's so [ __ ]
annoying I know I was like Smith
Schuster Juju Smith is such a cool name
hey Prime members you can listen to Life
Is Short ad free on Amazon music
download the Amazon music app today or
you can listen ad free with wondering
plus and apple podcasts before you go
tell us about yourself by completing a
short survey at wondery.com survey